don't be scared to be yourself
that's the first thing i will i will
tell people horrifying to stanford
because people think there's a perfect
mold
for an mba student that they have to
follow and that's simply not true
i interviewed with a ceo of a local
medical device company
so i was applying out of undergrad so to
go walk into a room and sit sit across
the table from a ceo
of a a public company was was a little
intimidating
as it would be for most people um i
think
the the thing that that stood out to me
from that experience was
it was a it was a fairly informal
conversation
um incredibly down to earth and really
he was actually he was more interested
in
you know what i wanted to do and what my
passions were than sort of validating
and checking boxes on do i fit
particular criteria
there's an overwhelming feeling when you
come to the gsb
that you're inadequate and you feel it
when you're applying you feel it when
you're talking to all the other people
that are applying
but if there's one thing that i've
learned this year is that i'm not
and that maybe i didn't work for
michelle obama
maybe i didn't cure polio
but i'm special in my way and if you
give yourself
that faith in yourself when you're
applying and push through the late
nights
the edits of your paper and the crying
maybe when you start thinking about
the pressures of writing them i would
say just have faith in yourself
and know if you don't apply then there's
definitely not a chance that you'll get
in
you